Let's do a recap of what we learned in this unit.
First, we talked about some Python features that were maybe new to you.
We used complex list comprehensions.
That's something like x-squared for x in blah, blah, blah, if something.
We showed generator expressions, and that's similar but with parentheses.
We talked about generator functions or just generators,
and we recognize those with the yield statement.
We talked about the idea of handling different types.
This has the fancy name of polymorphism, meaning different forms.
We saw an example of that in timed calls where we said that the input n--
and then there are other inputs there--n could be either an integer,
in which case we would do one thing, or a float, in which case we would do something else.
We checked which is which by using "isinstance."
We talked about the eval function and how we can use that to map from a string to a Python object,
which is the result of evaluating the string.
In particular, the case of evaluating to a function.
Eval is a way of making the computation be done once
and getting all that work over with so that we can then use that work repeatedly.
We also talked about instrumentation, and we did timing with the time.clock method
that's built in, and then we built up timedcall and timedcalls routine.
And we talked about counting number of invocations of functions
or assignment statements or whatever.
There we came up with our own routine that we called c.
I guess I should say a little bit about variable naming conventions.
Why did I use a short name like c here, whereas other places I had long, more expressive names?
I guess the reason is c was used only for debugging purposes.
It wasn't intended to be part of the final part of the program.
I felt justified in having that be short, because I was going to be typing it and deleting it frequently.
Things that are going to persist for longer have longer names
For example, it's fine to say "for i in range something"
where there we know that i is an index integer, and it only persists over this short loop.
It's okay to have a short name.
If something lasts longer, we probably want it to have a longer, more descriptive name.